previously on raft all right let's go in
this place you guys ready oh what is
that
what is that uh i think that's what the
tape is for if i remember
oh i think you gotta like oh three tape
okay i got one tape over here
ceiling i i might
[Applause]
i see a painting of a bear sucking a
dude's penis nose
this is this an apartment what the hell
oh bear sucking penis knows
mark how the ass did you get outside uh
yeah let me come get you man
so this zip line is just at slightly too
low an angle to go down that way
you can like get to kind of a running
start but yeah what if you what if you
like
hey i'm fine it's fine don't worry about
me
i think that might have worked if i
would have hit the zip line maybe
all right i'm fine this painting looks
like a purple girl kissing a yellow girl
and the yellow girl's looking to the
side like she might be kissing me but
i'm thinking of you poor purple girl has
no idea
go pitbull girl stop
this is terrifying i don't like doing
what i'm doing i mean there's no like
fall damage you'll be fine
why is there no fall damage this doesn't
make any sense well there is but it's
really weak
it's some push over size fall damn man
you guys have opened all
well that could be a yellow girl kissing
bacon i saw this as like hair and
another nose
that could be her yellow's nose kissing
some bacon i do see the bacon now
i don't know what you're talking about
my dude
oh sh hey i'm incapacitated oh wait i'm
in the building you are
oh good hey do you want some stone
arrows because i just had to toss some
wait i mean i'll pick them up if you
need can someone
wait someone could save me where are you
oh
right you're incapacitated i'm on the
ground outside okay let me find a
there's got to be like a way outside
from this building somewhere yep found
it
okay hang on i'm coming well before you
go too far i need you to
nope bob needs me bob needs me now
do we need more leather can i get rid of
some leather who needs leather
there's pretty valuable all right we
need leather leather it's hard to come
up with
plastic and i can get rid of super donut
plastic bob where are you
what do you see around you i can see the
water tower i'm like across
the way the water tower across on the
other side of the
water tower from the building that you
were in i think okay let's establish
the exit that our boat is at if that's
12 o'clock
where in the circle are you i would be
somewhere around maybe
four o'clock four o'clock okay i think i
was fighting a robot so there might be a
robot near me
okay four o'clock um maybe closer to
five
okay five are you towards the center oh
i see you i got you you were right four
o'clock good good
yeah you killed my friend how'd you get
outside from here
i jumped out the window the windows
aren't solid all right bob don't you
worry man you're really jiggly when i
carry you
i know i like to kick my legs it's fun
it's nice
it's cute don't you worry bob
don't you worry about the thing
everything out every little thing broken
window man we should get another bed
look at that wait you can break a window
apparently you don't want to do that
mark look at the droopy goat
oh
yeah oh killed the shark apparently
you mean that this whole time we could
have made our boat shark proof
this literally this whole time with
metal 100 yeah
my god i mean but you need like a lot of
metal
yeah but even so that's incredible just
snorted so hard i think i broke my nose
it's like when you broke your hand when
you were just playing a game and you got
really like in i didn't break it i
dislocated my wrist
by doing stink jazz hands i just you
were dislocated
i distinctly remember you going panicked
i broke my hand
like i really like genuinely thought i
thought i thought i did it hurt so bad
the angle at which my wrist was laying
was not
a natural one it was just sheer panic
yeah but i just
dislocated doing heavy jazz hands
we've all been there we've all
blown out a risk doing heavy jazz hands
that's for certain
oh this is where the coins are oh did
you find the vending machines oh you can
buy art yeah the good art
oh wow wait and food
my god oh you can buy a piano
is that a background i went
counter-clockwise around the outside i'm
just killing bots
doors locked from the other side okay
how do we get into the center column
that's the biggest question hello a good
a good question indeed
we gotta go in from the outside possibly
possibly
possibly maybe something maybe i don't
know
what did you say oh my god
wait why did you start doing heroin i
had a lot of saliva in my mouth
oh my god i was very salivating
oh yeah we could tell yeah over here
yeah mix of the goose
girth berms meme and the target lady
where did she get a piano
oh here's another open door oh here's an
unopened door never mind this is the one
that says screw off
got it key card reader is out of order
happens to the best of us you know what
happens when i screw on
yeah prior now
yeah you're right you got it nailed it i
don't like these rats that run to the
front door like a because i think it's a
puppy coming to greet me
oh cute that bites my dick okay so now
that i know the tokens are valuable i'm
gonna
look for them harder what do we do with
all this tape there's so much tape
well there's that thing down on the
interior that we can do i don't 100 know
what the excess tape is for because you
definitely get more than you need for
just the
the one thing yeah i like that these
apartments still have power and have
like music playing and stuff
do you think that the society collapsed
because no one figured out how to go
downstairs
and put in the three battery pieces that
were just all over the place
and that's right everyone up here was
just like what do we do
they couldn't solve that puzzle that you
had to solve wow everyone up here was
just like where are you
going honey save up for a piano
i want to know how you get a piano to
fit in a vending machine wouldn't you
like to know
let's build your own ikea up here in her
i call her tonight kierner
please laugh
thanks guys thank you thank you i'm
gonna get to this center tower if it's
the last thing i do
it almost is the last thing that you do
if it's the last thing that i
freaking do how in the f
do i get to this building oh language
guys how the
how the effing heck do i get in here oh
somebody freaking better tell me or i'm
gonna i'm gonna start swearing up a
story
no my monetization please my sweet
delicious monetization
become a tangaroa vip join the founders
society so there was
in this island where apparently this is
the or humanity's finest
there was another society inside of it
oh well you gotta have classes how do
you know who's better than who
i mean yeah you're right that's exactly
what happened if we did go into a like
first class only society
they would just filter out people to the
lower classes
if everyone's special then no one is you
and will be or whatever you know that
means
thank you palpatine that thing that
palpatine says yeah do it
separate the classes
oh use the elevator in the plantation
area
we gotta go back down
dumb idiots we're idiots someone just
spoil it for
did someone just give you the answer no
i read the i read the poster which is
actually the first poster i read in this
place
oh son of a [ __ ] it went back and i
read it and i was like
oh no we're idiots now i'm going to the
plantation
i'm right behind you i'm going i'm going
to
die of thirst down here but i'm going
for it i don't care give it to me can i
call you marco nobin
[Music]
sure man all right i was just i've been
wanting to ask you that for a couple of
minutes a couple years you know
really
wait i wanna don't do the elevator
without me i'm coming boys can i at
least tape up the thing
sure sure sure i'd take it oh why didn't
it fall you do that i have to be honest
one on the time before when i did this i
took the route of
i stayed on the raft and used the
obscene amount of resources we had
accumulated
to build outside of the dome all the way
up to the top of the dome
whoa so i didn't actually see all this
stuff
necessarily i built this
and then you know what i put up there
the steering wheel
[Laughter]
i built the tallest contraption ever
conceived of
did you just press something marcus yeah
just opened it i i taped it up again ow
oh i'm coming in my nudes wait where are
i'm in the plantation
hey friends oh hey ow ooey
owie okay
go go go oh my god we're going into the
elevator which way are we going on this
room here this door just opened
i called this vine use three tape got it
i did tape on this
all right cool man thank you is it done
electrifying oh yay
oh now can pop it out through it that's
a my name
no oh no i'm chopping down these nana
trees though cool
electric pyramid hell yeah
yeah check it out check it out this
doesn't make any sense
why is it people open the door oh we can
unlock this door i bet
oh wait wait wait wait wait hello oh
this is the door okay
okay this is the one i found where the
key card reader was broken oh yeah all
right
yeah that's the poster i read that lend
me down here let's said use the elevator
implantation
yeah man i stared right at that and
didn't read any of the words on it
because i was like i don't know what i'm
doing
that's exactly what i did the first time
i just saw like out of order i was like
oh man yes no good
i want to know before their society
collapsed why they went and removed all
the other buttons from these elevators
i don't know man there's the mark hold
on can i get your artistic uh
interpretation yeah what's up yeah
what's up
is this two people kissing or is this
bacon ooh and a person
good question good question
okay so i see this is like a smile on
the side
and this is an eye here and he's got a
black eye uh the red one's a black eye
okay yeah that's the hair if you look at
it from this side yeah that's the hair
one person who has one person yeah
exactly
i see this as one person with long
red dish maroonish hair and then their
eyes closed and that's like their eye
shadow
yeah yeah yeah
you thought this was two girls making
out
or a person kissing bacon do you see the
rectangle like the little square in the
middle sure
sure i thought that was a nose from a
person on the right and you could only
see their nose and their hair
but somebody else was like oh but it
looks like a person who's kissing like
some bacon
but i don't know what the rectangle is
in that instance i also with the
sideways person
i don't know what the rectangle is for
the sideways person is it's just like
they're wearing like a a headband or
something decorational
i don't know it's the shadow of their
hair or something yeah yeah
yeah something like that well listen
with us you're gone he's seen it what i
saw
did we search this room already
pool table piano oh there's a rat
monster oh did you start stuck in the
bush painting
no no is that down there yeah that's
still here too
oh i see that
sounds like you're struggling to kill
the rat man i really am
guys uh i'm dying to thirst my dude i
got a
whole bottle of water if you need
something i'm in the next building i zip
lined over can you hear me
okay well i'm just gonna leave i guess
we're done looking around
thanks mark well i don't have to be i'll
last a little longer but if you
wait too long i'll i'll you know die and
how
where where's the zip line at buddy
i don't know here we are i see yes i'm
gonna come back down now to the piano
there's a piano yeah but you can't play
it it's stupid hey buddy
hey what's up man you need some wawa
yeah i didn't refill my bottle
oui hi oh oh
oh thank you i'll give you the bottle
back once i'm done with it
how many tangodua tokens do we have how
many tangly dangly tokens
oh you know a spoiler that'll make you
want the piano even more
you can play it you can actually play
the piano
you can sit at the piano and it has
music on it and it tries to
play songs mom and i both had to stop
and look at the bear
i looked like it was from a different in
a different aspect ratio or something
but i think it was just because it was
on the edge of my screen
oh guys it's this one
oh yeah what's this one
it's this one it's this one oh [ __ ] it's
the good one
hang on wait don't don't get in my way
with all right you got it
ye there we go oh god ah
what the careful
i see what you're saying to be careful
about yeah the the ladder's a little
slippery at the top
the top of the lapper's lapper is
terrifying
okay oh in here oh fast oh i can call
the elevator maybe oh i just called the
elevator
cool well let's get out of this room
oh we're we're it's on one and this
elevator goes to zero
and one and two oh wait
zero first or two first zero would
unlock the front door
i think why not yeah let's do it in case
we all die stupidly that would be good
that was really fast
i feel like that was too quick oh hey
right there
oh no transcribe no sir they haven't
done anything hostile they're just
chanting sounds malay we can use the
water cannons
yes sir i'm armed but if if they i may
speak freely
we have no reason for no sir yes sir
dolly says shoot to wound
yeah what an a-hole shoot the wound
shoot to mame
aim for their gallbladder they don't
need that
ah floor two that's what it's all about
wow oh i see blueprints what's that
let me read you this note here tranquil
street
exterior lane bazaar street partisan
road
i don't know what this is i just want to
hang out with the elevator music
i want to launch the bridge
launch the bridge emergency bridge
launch we have to find the bridge launch
code oh
okay so what i'm picking up from this
note is
there the code would be hidden on these
items that are on the buildings of these
road that are in the buildings on these
roads so you got to look for the items
is that my right
maybe it sounds like i'm right what a
weird way to make a call
oh we're not meant to tell you that
you're not quite right actually
keep guessing keep guessing i don't know
also this is where i skip to
if you build if you build a ramp from
the raft outside the dome
this is where you can get to and i
actually built it all the way up to that
ladder you can see up there
without ever going inside or solving
anything
turns out you can't get in from the
outside so it's kind of pointless
but i did it we need to find the hair
curlers steak the cheeseburger the
scissors
and the doughnut these are the shops oh
that's what i was trying to work with so
i'll look for the one
on partisan road whatever that is
i'll look for the one on exterior i
don't know where
other street nate how the [ __ ] you know
signs signs with sinclair
just like in regular life okay i found
bizarre it's over at uh about 12 o'clock
from our previous lease
memory lane oh this one's called memory
lane
partisan road right okay
floating fashion oh three
all right so three is for scissors no
three is for
the the the life raft three
burgers the barber the barber means
something right i found the burger
the burger is eight burger is eight
so something eight something three got
it uh the barber looks like it might be
a four
if it's the sign is it the number on the
like the arcade where the barber sign is
i think it's the number it would be on
the building yeah it would be on the
building under the barber sign
yeah so what was the number what'd you
say so the barber says bizarre street
i'm i think i'm at the wrong place i'm
at the arcade
like they're okay they're arcades one of
them yeah kate is four
on tranquil street the arcade is four
what was that number is four what was
barbara
we don't know and then yours i thought
wade just said it didn't he no no
way it was on tranquil street oh there
was a sign for the barber
arcade so four eight something three
four eight one three four eight one
three to the elevator
to the elevator four eight one three i'm
gonna do
the food over here thank you
you're so sweet to be okay who wants to
do it
you by all means one of you two oh okay
get him all right oops i pressed the
wrong number
glad we solved this mystery three one
yeah is that not is that not good what
do you mean launch initiated
go to hell game that thing just blew up
i know it was the bridge of the
enterprise we were launched i thought it
was a bridge to walk on oh it fell in
the ocean
it's in the water it did it did how
about that can we
can i just run down there you can i'm
going to try and find the raft real
quick because i'm out of
giblets i'm going for it oh wow that is
just there
what good was that going to do anybody
everyone in there is probably fine oh
this is
oh how oh god make sure you jump
off much balance out to see
than i thought it was sharp oh yeah
you know that's fine
this is i it it looked closer from where
i was up there yeah well we were like on
top of a skyscraper yeah
my real perspective is real funny we
should have brought the raft over to
this that would have been the way to go
yeah i'm fine oh hi bob there you are oh
guys don't don't just
stay in any more shark targets i'm still
in the water that's great man good for
you
oh bye daddy time
all right look at this oh yeah this guy
looks like uh
this guy looks no good
all right go in the hole no no
no it's so dark hannah and mysterio
uh ooh what's the note saying uh it's
just the future next update it's got one
of
those
a water tank water tank oh hell
yeah i mean technically for the
automated sprinkler i think we already
knew how to make a water tank
considering that has kind of a reservoir
built into it
no but the water tank is what you run
the piping to and the electric guy too
he really should have brought the boat
over here shouldn't we have probably yes
well nose goes bob's got the flippers
okay
i do not have flippers i won't bother
with the apology i know that you
couldn't have done better if she's
crashed tengero was built on a period
theoretical basis using engines that had
barely been tested staffed by fools that
weren't ready for the task ad
tangaro was doomed for the moment we say
well it sounds like i could have done
a lot better jesus christ the raft
people whipped themselves onto the
bubble i thought they were trying to
come in
but if we had taken them in we wouldn't
have lasted three days those rioting
outside would think
i was wrong to give the orders to shoot
but they weren't the ones having to make
the tough decisions i wish
i had made a better choice well if there
was a better choice then someone could
have done better
i had the pets rounded up to stop people
from doing anything too desperate
when the food ran out they can call me a
monster if they want they need one now
anyway a big old monster trapped in the
cockpit
with two dozen idiots that used to run
the world what i did will help them
focus give them strength to leave this
place one way or another
and when everyone is out else is out of
here i will be the last person to leave
tangora this guy just seems like an
idiot can we drive this bad boy let's
pilot this thing
i like how his his note was just like
yeah i did my best yeah
[ __ ] it you know try try again whatever
so i'm done
wonder what it makes you wonder if the
painting of the bear was based on him
maybe oh i'm dying to thirst again can
you guys bring the boat around
i don't have flippies i'm probably gonna
die if i try
oh god you only die once yeah whatever
[ __ ] it you know start over
so what i built this amazing floating
island and i couldn't figure out how to
get
food our shark boy is actually pretty
damaged so uh if we uh
encounter it might be able to kill it uh
sure the three of us
united together uh-huh all three of us
are going right
look i'm starving i can't move very
quick you you got this man
that's fair i see one of the oh we why
didn't we open all the ramps
we'd open up all the ramps that could be
back in the dome and just running over
to it
hey bob you there bob's just taking it
all in i get that
bob's gone you're dying and i'm swimming
with the sharks
yeah life couldn't be better life could
not be better actually
i don't even know how to pilot this rat
i've not driven this raft like ever
okay so i need to turn on the engines
probably need to flip the direction that
it's going in
probably yep great we're not moving
that's a good sign right the anchor's
down so you got to lift the end oh
there's an anchor
yeah can i say so
all right anchor up i'm gonna get some
water so i don't die on the way there
that's good choice man hey if i'm dead
here it's fine are we all dying
i am but it's okay man's getting the
boat he's bringing it around
wait fetch the boat wait come on god oh
that's not what you want to see
everything's fine everything's good why
did we put the steering wheel so far
away
go away go go wade go
all right change the direction of the
engines i am going
well we're dying wade all right wait
i'll see you around
the engines are on i'm at the house damn
it i should have leaned where i
was gonna anchor race yep anchors up
yeah
all right what did you say mark you
should have what i should have fell so i
would be looking out at the ocean i only
see
here you might reposition you buddy yeah
if you could just lay me so i can see
uh not quite nah opposite way
spin me okay okay okay how's that let's
see
uh nah still gray
right hang on i'll find you a spot buddy
don't you what if i wedge you up here
i might have gotten the long way around
i'm still turned the wrong way
what if i wedge you up here no i seem to
always turn the other way a piece of
[ __ ] ah
it ain't happening man what if i can i
like show you the ocean if i hold you
like this
uh you'd have to turn the other way my
head's on your on your backside
this way oh yeah that's nice that's good
this is me pointing your ass at the
ocean so apparently you see out your ass
apparently is this shocking to anybody
really though
oh there he is beautiful but he's over
there i don't see him turn me a little
more
other way see him you see him there all
the way out of the way other way a
little more a little more a little more
stamina
[Applause]
no no it's gotta be the bad version the
recorder
i mean that was a pretty bad version
give me the lo-fi version uh you assume
he knows what that means
yeah i i'm going to pretend i do
is that lo-fi i'm sorry do you think
lo-fi
means 1920s jazz
is that lo-fi it was a low i guess you
got there
give us the hard rock version
nice give me um uh
rap give me the rap version
mark and i are dead inside each other's
asses now oh drop an anchor
all right how do i stop this thing uh
just drop the anchor just do the anchor
first it'll stop drop
i got an unstuck button i don't know
what the unstuck button does
it'll just make you spawn in a different
place unrelated to where you are it's a
terrible thing it's how you lose a dead
person
if you if i go into the ocean while i'm
dead do i just sink down to the very
bottom
no you float it's all right thanks man
thank you one bum in the bed
we have two bags away from march
together i'm all better man
hey by the time i get there you'll be
right as rain hey you gotta paint it i
have a bed
oh yeah hell yeah this is pretty cool
man
we did it guys
[Music]
oh